now that did nothing really oh oh that's
bad run run run run run run run damn we
need to get the [ __ ] out of here yeah
don't hurry or anything you just might
the iron that was it now there she is
sorry my buy something else
my my Maya Maya Maya finally I'll
actually take that in case I [ __ ] up
again say music
yeah my saving okay so we have to go in
here
let's go I'm poke what be wait yeah
first away try it
my al
the [ __ ]
yeah I ain't got that you saw me three
times something here maybe yeah look
there it is ah sorry I click past it I
don't feel like going back is there a
dead beaver I thought I saw been that
mean
yes then we were just
okay
I would say the story in this game is
really interesting I'm really curious to
see what will happened but I'm really
really really really really really
confused to should be here some oh it's
probably that pendant
oh it's where the dolls are oh I hate
dolls
we're wait on the door yeah
what
a different place shows in the photo it
looks countless handprints on the wall
I said walking over the diamond stickpin
and finally there's my another
that's so creepy
no he's mean I don't remember if I seem
that thing on the wall but I guess we
have to go back where's the door
there's the door
this is a Sun good
I'm missing door some way are the
handprints somewhere
you know what can may be left here I
mean right
nothing really looks like a dead beaver
to me
[Music]
we wear
but
the what the ritual will have have so
confused so confused
oh I'll do a save state I'm number six
in case I need to go back and I'm too
lazy just saying it could save me some
time oh [ __ ]
that was [ __ ] love this I won't eat
sushi then okay might be in here cuz I
seen one since oh no it's that thing
again
hope not on these
oh [ __ ]
yep no cell no effect
Oh click away clickety-clack
okay so I guess we can't go there back
get me did we walk here shiny object
kind of there so mirror there's an
obvious hair covered by a lot cause I
close so what do I do with it
hmm medicines purifying water resources
string revives you only one time when
strength is Sara able to photograph
things in this mood I know flashlights
all radio black [ __ ] confused really
confused so why the [ __ ] are we supposed
to go then
do you know don't you - say it's obvious
don't you - yes I am around however I
can hear you can you hear from here yes
it's not very obvious what am I supposed
to do there's one corridor I don't wait
I thought I saw something I think
nothing sorry
I'm not coming over
of course it is wow I got to miss a room
or something seriously
it's not in here that's for sure
maybe the drawers I don't know
[Music]
wait
wait wait seriously don't wait
SuperDuper wait where did the game go
Hey
I'll pause in here for now alright
welcome back to fatal frame with fatal
frames fatah flan I don't know what to
call it hey miss French more likely
Asian or Japanese or whatever I know
where to go I think maybe we can sneak
past that big scary go swinging
that's my only guess cuz I checked every
freaking room there is so Wow
Miami man I don't know who knows I know
because I'm a genius
maybe not but whatever
it's raining printed I don't get wet
from rain perfect I like that I like
that let's go let's skip it just got
down the stairs well it's kind of down
the stairs skip it to Skybound of stairs
ha ha ha
Skippy just got down the stairs skip it
escape down the stairs
skip it ASCAP down the stairs look at me
going down the stairs
ok sorry that's enough of that uh-huh
and then we go back in here and then the
big big big big I gotta do this safe
stay here [ __ ] hurry same s I'm using
and now the big big big scary mean Mean
Girls
hey this [ __ ] kills you on one shot so
I really have to hurry past them I don't
want to come at you bro ok his name is
me you her name is MIA whatever [ __ ]
let's go ok ok
why do you want for me [ __ ] mister
the twins
excuse me men oh man that's really
creepy
what where am I oh okay this follow
where that up
I see something
cracking door shut up there's the hand
bug there's a hand blood and yet okay
okay okay okay try and shiny object okay
we got it
know what let's take a picture of the
door I guess
now that did nothing good
yeah good and waste your film all you
want
let's see if I care No
okay come on buns
where